hey YouTube I'm SCP explained and this
is also SCP explained before we get into
today's story go ahead and smash that
like button and ring the bell to be
notified every time one of our epic
videos hits your subscription feed and
don't forget to share this video with
everyone you know friends family members
pets and even the sweaty guy at the bus
stop alright that's more than enough
pandering to the algorithm for one video
or is it because today we'll be talking
about another one of Dr Bright's many
Misadventures for those of you who don't
know and if you don't I'm wondering why
you clicked on this video Dr Jack Bright
is one of the most chaotic and
unpredictable researchers working at the
foundation his status as an immoral
Consciousness means that even his most
hair brain schemes rarely have lasting
consequences for the man himself the
same cannot be said about the amount of
collateral damage those same schemes
cause mind you and quite recently Dr
bright decided to attempt one of the
most dangerous and immoral acts that a
human being or humanoid anomaly is
capable of that's right Dr bright has
started a YouTube channel I know I
should have given a fair warning before
saying something so alarming but sadly
it's true and much like every time Dr
bright gets an idea like this into his
crazy little head the rest of us just
have to watch and wait for the
inevitable backfire to play itself out
so sit back and enjoy the show as Dr
bright becomes the aspiring YouTuber Mr
bright the first video on Mr Bright's
channel is a short audio visual remix
simply titled cleft music it begins with
Jack Bright sneaking up behind fellow
researcher and occasionally respected
colleague Dr Alto cleff with the
pepperoni pizza in hand Dr Clough
appears to be totally unaware of
Bright's approach and is utterly shocked
when bright smears the entire pizza
cheese topping sauce and all across his
face the rest of the video is a
recording of cleft's angered reaction
set to electronic dance music with
certain phrases enhanced through the use
of Auto-Tune the top comment from user
not kondraki reads oh I get it his name
is alto clef and he's singing There's a
reply to that same comment from user
three mini guns that says Jack delete
this in all caps the video received
about 1 000 views over three days which
wasn't much by the standards of most
well-known YouTubers but it was more
than enough encouragement for Mr bright
to keep the content train a moving but
what to do next after all auto-tune
remixes hadn't been at the peak of their
popularity in almost a decade prank
videos had also evolved to a level of
elaborate absurdity that far surpassed
the novelty of a pie to the phase Mr
bright would have to get creative if he
wanted to remain even somewhat relevant
in the ever-evolving YouTube algorithm
he eventually decided to release a vlog
series titled my life in sight 19 during
which bright would film his daily
routine in one of the most secure
Foundation containment sites in
existence needless to say the o5 council
had the first video in the series taken
down almost immediately via YouTube's
copyright strike system a breach of
classified information like that
couldn't be allowed to be freely
accessed on the internet even if the
total views on the video at the time of
the takedown had barely cracked 300.
Jack realized his channel was going
nowhere fast as he only had around 10
subscribers and most of them were
members of the research team that he had
personally told to subscribe he had to
find a way to bring the numbers up
without getting in further trouble with
the o5 console that's when it hit him
he'd conceal his identity with some kind
of Cartoon Avatar or as they were
sometimes known in the YouTube World a
rant Sona maybe someone that sort of
looked like him but was abstract enough
that no nobody would know there was any
ties between his channel and the
foundation so he drew up a few sketches
and eventually settled on a design for
his rant Sona that captured his
personality and could be placed on
screen whenever he didn't want to appear
on camera it was an unfortunate wake-up
call when Mr bright found out that not
only were Caucasian men with brown hair
far from uncommon in the world of
YouTuber ransonas a fair amount of them
also sported glasses there was at least
one other ransona that wore a lab coat
just like his own before long Mr bright
was receiving a ton of comments
comparing him to these other creators
saying that he was both a rip-off and a
trend Chaser Mr bright couldn't believe
it all that work to fit in among the
ransonas only to wind up being called
generic but he was nothing if not
resourceful and the researcher turned
YouTuber realized he could use this turn
of events to his Advantage he released
his next video titled why I'm leaving
this community while he never specified
what community he was leaving or any
specific grievance towards another
YouTuber Mr bright did spend a lot of
time talking about the YouTube terms of
service and how making the like to
dislike bar invisible was causing him
undue stress that had required him to
distance himself from making videos for
a while he ended the video by firmly
stating enough was enough and that he
wouldn't take it anymore again never
specifying what it was the video got 17
000 views in the first two days since
its upload and the comments were filled
with users of plotting Mr bright for his
bravery and apparent ability to speak
his mind overnight his subscribers grew
to 500 and countless comments continued
to pour in showing support for the
nebulous cause that Mr Bright Now stood
for now this was the response Mr bright
had been looking for and he planned to
grow his audience even further by
playing into the vague
anti-establishment angle that is
previous video had suggested he appeared
in front of the camera himself in the
video YouTube doesn't want you to see
this this time skewing all Foundation
apparel and filming against a green
screened background of an absurdly large
kitchen with spotless white cabinets the
kitchen was of course a
computer-generated image Mr bright had
devised to show that he was successful
and Wealthy but also casual and down to
earth over the course of the video Mr
bright insisted that some unnamed
higher-ups at YouTube were trying to
silence him and that nearly every video
he made was allegedly being demonetized
this claim was made despite the fact
that Mr bright was actually not yet able
to become a member of YouTube's partner
program because he hadn't met the
subscriber threshold to start earning ad
Revenue still he was certain that
centering himself in controversy would
be a Surefire way to gain more
subscribers however he was proven very
wrong within hours of the videos
released the commenters were tearing Mr
bright right apart calling him a liar
and a fake like a pack of tiny amateur
detectives Mr Bright's audience turned
on him and his reputation began to turn
sour response videos came out later in
the week bashing Mr Bright's YouTube
channel and accusing him rightfully so
of spreading misinformation this was
perhaps the biggest setback yet though
the channel had grown a bit as he had
hoped the small fan base surrounding it
had turned incredibly defensive every
comment section on a video talking about
Mr bright was a war zone between
self-proclaimed bright stands and anyone
unlucky enough to anger them the worst
part was Mr bright himself had no idea
what the arguments were even about at
this point he wasn't sure what he said
or did that had caused such a polarized
reaction he tried to win the audience
back with a few more Dr clef prank
videos but it was no use claff had
gotten wise to Bright's YouTube plans
and whenever he was on screen he would
speak with so much profile identity that
the audio would become basically
unusable additionally he would fire
several of his guns into the air in a
wild and dangerous fashion these factors
meant that Jack had to shelve pretty
much every video involving clef and the
ones that he was able to edit all the
swears and gunshots out of were
borderline incomprehensible it was clear
enough that the Mr bright brand was on
its way out and Dr bright had to make
peace with that he had essentially three
options available to him number one
Rebrand and hope that the previous
audience forgets about the controversy
surrounding the channel number two start
an entirely new YouTube channel as if
nothing had ever happened or number
three give up on being a YouTuber
entirely option number three certainly
wasn't going to happen and to commit to
option 2 would mean losing the
subscribers and Views he had already
gained so really only the prospect of a
total Rebrand could make any of this
seemingly futile struggle worthwhile it
had to be option one in order for this
to work Dr bright had to choose a new
form of content that was so low effort
that he couldn't possibly be perceived
as bad at it he had been watching a
number of YouTube videos for research
and eventually he decided that reaction
content was the ideal way to make a
bunch of videos without having to spend
too much time on each individual one all
he had to do was wait for other creators
to make the content and he would record
his unscripted reactions he could
potentially do this all day provided he
continued to supply himself with other
YouTube videos of course there was a
slight issue of how he would have to
present himself in these videos his face
was already somewhat known in the
community at large and is now all but
discarded ransona would cause similar
problems then Dr bright was struck with
another Epiphany during a late night
session of obsessive content research
which had regretfully been taking the
place of the actual SCP research he was
supposed to be doing Dr Wright fell
asleep on his desk with the autoplay
feature on he awoke several hours later
to hear the sounds of a virtual YouTuber
or vtuber reacting to content the same
way he was hoping to do on his channel a
v tuber rig of course Dr bright thought
to himself the answer had been right in
front of him by rigging his body
movements to a 3D animated character he
would have a baseline level of an
amenity and the capacity to
realistically translate his reactions
into the digital realm this was genius
his channel would soar into popularity
once he created an appealing virtual
character to embody himself Goodbye Mr
bright and hello v-tuber bright but of
course he had to design the Avatar
himself acquire the correct software and
learn how to utilize all of it before
stepping once again into a world of
comparisons to similar content on second
thought this this was not going to be
anywhere near as easy as Dr bright
initially thought it would be perhaps
there was no easy ways to get views on
YouTube and obtaining positive success
and notoriety on the platform wasn't
something that had a simple clear-cut
answer maybe this latest Venture had
taught Dr Wright that being himself and
focusing on his work was ah he didn't
learn anything like that he just decided
to take a big shortcut through all the
real hard work that goes into becoming a
v tuber because when Dr Wright is faced
with a problem that can't be overcome
through non-anomalous means he finds the
right SCP for the job and solves it the
supposedly easy way with the quote
supposedly doing a lot of heavy lifting
in that sentence in the case of his
current V tuber aspirations Dr bright
Enlisted the help of
scp-1471 Mao o the skullfaced SCP
already dwelled inside of virtual space
and though it was perhaps just a
coincidence based on the specific
YouTuber Dr bright had stumbled upon it
seemed that humanoid wolves had been
proven to be quite popular with the
typical vtuber audience besides Dr
bright wasn't aware of the um
sort of people who were always eager to
join
scp-1471's fan club
um sorry research team with only a few
minor modifications to its programming
Malo was able to perform all the
essential functions of a v-tuber rig Dr
Wright would move his arms or head in
the meat space and Malo would mimic the
movements like it was some kind of
shared game between the two since
scp-1471 didn't have a voice of its own
Dr bright provided a very spiritual
vocal performance through his own
microphone after a few test runs the
dynamic duo of SCP and researcher had
succeeded in becoming one complete
vtuber his initial plans to become a
popular and well-respected YouTuber may
have failed and the original channel
name of Mr bright soon faded from the
internet's Collective memory but Dr
Bright's determination to keep on
grinding and adapt to new forms of
content was something that any
up-and-coming Creator could find in
firing that is unless they too had let
countless hours of important research on
dangerous anomalies fall to the Wayside
in pursuit of Internet Fame if that is
the case maybe what is best for some
would be YouTubers to not leave their
day job so soon especially not when the
lives of millions hang in the balance
now go check out
scp-963 what would you do if you were
immortal like Dr Jack Bright and can Dr
bright defeat billionaire Jeff Bezos for
more classic Dr bright Adventures